Was lange währt, wird endlich gut - unter
diesem Titel sehen Politiker von CDU, CSU
und SPD offenbar die Einigung der Parteien auf einen Koalitionsvertrag.
Der geschäftsführende Innenminister, der
für die CDU verhandelt hatte, Thomas de Maziere
zeigte sich am Mittwoch zufrieden.
Kurz vor seinem Statement war bekannt geworden,
dass er einer neuen Bundesregierung nicht mehr angehören wird.
"Ich bin sehr stolz und sehr dankbar, dass ich in drei schwierigen Ressorts diesem Land dienen durfte.
Ich freue mich darüber, dass eine neue, stabile Regierung zustande kommt
und ich wünsche meinem Nachfolger im Amt des Innenministeriums alles Gute und viel Erfolg."
Auch die Verteilung wichtiger Regierungsressorts wurde am Mittwoch bekannt.
Dazu CSU-Generalsekretär Andreas Scheuer.
"Das Wahlergebnis der Bundestagswahl hat uns alle nicht zufrieden gestellt,
die jetzt in den letzten Tagen am Tisch gesessen sind.
Und deswegen ist die CSU sehr zufrieden mit einem super Innenministerium,
das angereichert ist mit Bauen, Wohnen und Heimat - und einem starken Investitionsministerium aus Verkehr
und dem Bereich Digitales, und auch mit der außenpolitischen Kompetenz der CSU mit dem
wichtigen Ministerium für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit, Also rundum ein gutes Paket."
Im Bereich Befristung von Arbeitsplätzen
und in der Gesundheitspolitik sind nach Ansicht
des SPD-Generalsekretärs Hubertus Heil Fortschritte
erzielt worden.
"Ich bin erstmal froh, dass die SPD zentrale
Ressorts für sich markiert hat.
Es gibt eine Chance, zum Beispiel in der Europapolitik,
zu einem neuen Aufbruch zu kommen.
In der Finanz- und Steuerpolitik wird sozialdemokratische Handschrift auch in den Ressorts da sein.
Und dass wir bei Arbeit und Soziales unsere Position weiterhin durchsetzen können."
Die Reform des Gesundheitssektors soll einer Kommission übergeben werden,
hieß es ebenfalls am Mittwoch.